now britain's centre-left prime minister
magdalena anderson has conceded defeat
and announced that she's stepping down
following sunday's general election
anderson's social democratic party and
their left-wing coalition are lost by a
thin margin and to the conservative bloc
which includes the far-right sweden
democrats a party that has its roots in
a neo-nazi movement in the 1980s and 90s
a turning point in swedish politics
magdalena anderson concedes defeat in
the country's parliamentary election
it looks like the four right-wing
parties have received just 50 percent of
the votes in the election and in
parliament they have a one or two seat
advantage it's a thin majority but it's
a majority
it's a major hit to the prime minister's
social democrats
they have governed sweden since 2014 and
dominated the country's political
landscape since the 1930s
now this man ulf christensen is expected
to form a government
his blog includes the sweden democrat a
far-right party that has vowed to make
sweden safe again by bringing in longer
prison sentences and restricting
immigration
people in the capital reacted to the
news of the block's narrow win
it's a sad sign of the times that we're
living in that they can
profile themselves on scaring up scaring
the people with
that
where it's unsafe to live in sweden with
the
with all the criminals and all the
activities and so forth
that only affects about one or two
percent of the people of sweden most
people they live a very very very secure
life so how they can win an election on
that
it's ridiculous there are a lot of big
questions in our society today
that in some ways hasn't been addressed
correctly and i think a lot of people
have been longing for a change
even though that change
sometimes means shifting the
the polarity to the right in this case
sunday's vote was one of the closest
elections ever in sweden
thousands of overseas and postal votes
were needed to get a clearer picture of
who the winner was
however it could take weeks to form a
government
let's take a look at what this is likely
to mean with marcus carlson who's a
presenter and reporter for tv4 in
stockholm welcome to dw
does a right wheat
right leaning government that includes a
far right to party mean that sweden will
necessarily lurch to the right
i mean it's clear that the sweden
democrats will have more influence than
they ever had before with the more than
20 percent
of the vote exactly what their influence
will be well the jury's still out on
that because now uh these parties of the
right that have won the election they
have to uh strike a coalition agreement
just like in germany and many other
countries how long that will take is
unclear at the moment and how difficult
and arduous that process is also unclear
at the moment what is clear or what
appears fairly clear is that the sweden
democrats actually won't be part of the
government why is that well because the
liberal party also part of this winning
coalition has said that it won't accept
the sweden democrats within an actual
government so what it is likely is some
sort of uh supply and confidence
agreement between the sweden democrats
and the other parties of the right-wing
coalition but as i say it's
difficult to say exactly what kind of
influence and what kind of relationship
these parties will have going forward
okay so no sweden democrats
in government
but the uh prime minister of the third
largest party in parliament is going to
have to rely
on votes
from the sweden democrats in order to
push his agenda through so how does he
do that how does he convince a larger
party to go his way
well
there are certain points
over which these parties agree that
includes energy these parties all want
to build more nuclear power for instance
it includes defense issues it includes
certain migration issues um so there are
um
some
common points here that these parties
can take forward there are also some
issues that uh where where these parties
disagree um i'm thinking for example of
asylum issues i'm thinking about foreign
aid the sweden democrats they want to
cut down on foreign aid traditionally
that has been
a red line for the christian democrats
and the liberal party they don't want to
cut down on foreign aid so
once again these are issues that will
have to be hashed out in the days and
weeks to come and it's difficult to see
exactly where this will come down
and just taking a step back from the the
deal making in government to look at the
result itself we have the far right
winning voters by focusing on rising
crime rates in a small number of
immigrant neighborhoods across the the
country so why was this such an
important issue for swedes
well there have been hundreds of
shootings so far this year and also more
than 40 people killed
in these shootings
in a country
such as sweden with just about 10
million inhabitants of course that is
fairly big number and i think what's
been worrying people
in the past few months or so is that
this violence these shootings haven't
just occurred in the
in the suburbs of stockholm for instance
or in other suburbs in malmo and
gutenberg they have actually
happened also in smaller cities and
smaller towns
in sweden that has been something that's
been brought up in the campaign once
quite a lot of times that um the
shootings are are spreading they're
going up in number but they're also
spreading geographically to smaller
towns and cities
good talking to you that was very clear
uh marcus carlson uh from sweden's tv
four thank you
thank you